[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: BigQuery can process
enormous amounts of data.
Adding cost controls can protect
you from runaway queries,
whether you have multiple
BigQuery projects and users,
or it's just you.
You can manage costs by
setting a custom quota that
specifies a limit on the
amount of query data processed
per day.
This video will take you through
the process of establishing
your own custom quotas.
You may set quotas to control
costs at the project level
or at the user level.
Project level custom quotas
limit the aggregate usage
of all users in that project,
while user level custom quotas
are separately applied
to each user or service
account within a project.
You may use either of
these quota options,
or both in tandem.
Used in tandem, usage will
count against both quotas
and adhere to the stricter
of the two limits.
An example scenario can be found
at the documentation linked
below.
Start by navigating
to the Quotas menu
in the IAM and Admin console.
Make sure you have the
right project selected.
Filter the quotas for
the BigQuery API service.
Check the box for Query Usage
Per Day and/or Query Usage
Per Day Per User.
And click Edit Quotas.
Set your email and phone number.
These contact details may
be used when processing
certain quota requests.
Enter your daily
quotas in tebibytes.
Notice that the quotas
are in tebibytes,
so be sure to make any
necessary conversions.
Click Done and then
click Submit Request.
Review the changes
and click Confirm.
Quota changes should take
effect within a few minutes.
Once the quotas are set, if
project level or user level
custom quotas are exceeded,
BigQuery returns an error.
Daily quotas reset at
midnight Pacific Time.
For more information
on custom quotas please
visit the documentation
and FAQs linked below.
Happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]